Hello, everyone.
My name is Benjamin but you can call me Uncle Ben.
Zambia today is one of the highest deforestation area in Africa and in the world in general.
We are, therefore, trying to work with Greenpop to see if there is something that can be done.
In 2012, Greenpop came to Livingstone in Zambia to set up a conference...
...on what we called "Trees for Zambia".
The event was very successful.
We had people from all over the globe.
And we really enjoyed ourselves because we're everywhere, in schools, in communities, in farms,...
...and we planted a lot of trees.
Greenpop is again organizing this year from 7th to 28th of July.
And this time, we hope to have a lot of you come along to join us in Livingstone...
...which is the home of the mighty Victoria Falls.
We are all welcoming you to this event and I'm sure you'll enjoy yourself.
Let's come together and find a solution to the deforestation...
...that is taking place in Livingstone.
You're welcome, all of you.
So please come along and join us.
Let's all say, "Treevolution".
Thank you.